no dreams  the future i can see it  i need you by my side well if i'm not  the future of house of treaty  you'll still be the only thing i ever  needed you to be my son  let's fight like demons  put on some muscle  i didn't  no  [Music]  a great man doesn't seek to lead he's  called to it  and he answers  my son  we'll find a way  will you protect our son  with my life  why didn't you say you were a fighter  jessica you've been training him in the  way do you see so little  hope a path has been made let's hope he  doesn't squander it  hello young master  why is dr you a here spicy so  psychoactive chemical you seem to be  sensitive  i've been having dreams they're picking  my family off one by one  [Applause]  smile gurney i am smiling you've never  met harkins before they're not human  they're brutal  you're on the moon today  you fight when the necessity arises  fight  i see you found the mood  you